حل الحديث عن هذا الموضوع انضم الينا من
الخرطوم اسامه ابو بكر المسؤول الاعلامي
للهلال الاحمر السوداني استاذ اسامه اعتقد
بان هذه اخبار سعيده بالنسبه لكم استئناف
انشطه برنامج الاغذيه العالمي وايضا
المساعدات التي بدات تصل الى اي مدى سيسهل
هذا عملكم في ظل هذه الظروف بالسودان
اكيد ده حيكون عندي دور كبير جدا في
انفراج الازمه
ودي اخبار فعلا سعيده في حجم الماساه يعني
والاحساس بالحزن الموجود طبعا
المساعدات الحتجي من برنامج الغذاء
العالمي او اي من المؤسسات العالميه
اكيد حتستفيد منها اللي هيستفيد منها
المواطنين وضحايا النزاع المسلح ودائما
نحن عندنا الشراكات مع كل هذه المنظمات
التابعه للامم المتحده وغيرها في انه هي
بتعتمد على الهلال الاحمر بالذات في توزيع
المساعدات سواء كانت مساعده صحيه او
انسانيه على مستوى السودان فضلا عن
الخرطوم لانه الهلال الاحمر السوداني
يعتمد في عمله اساسا على متطوعين متخصصين
في مجالات مختلفه يبلغ عددهم قريب النصف
مليون متطوره في جميع انحاء السودان هل
استلمتم هذه
الشحنه التي تم ارسالها من العاصمه
الاردنيه والى اي مدى هي تفي
بحاجياتكم وما المطلوب من خلال الدعم
القادم ما اهم ما تحتاجونه في المرحله هذه
طبعا بنحتاج
للمعينات الطبيه
مختلف المعينات الطبيه ونستلزمات الطبيه
والشحنه القادمه من اللجنه الدوليه للصليب
الاحمر هي فيها كل المستلزمات الطبيه حسب
الاولويات المطروحه بحكم انه اللجنه
الدوليه القريبه عندها جثه قائمه منذ
عشرات السنين في السودان ونعمل مع بعض
سويا لذلك كل الاشياء الجايه في الشحنه دي
اولويه طبعا الشحنه يعني
هي 8 طن او 8000 كيلو يعني وبالتالي هتحدث
انفراج كبير جدا لكنها لم تحل الازمه طبعا
لكنها حتساعد بشكل كبير ونحن بنتمنى انه
الشحنه دي تكون اول الغيث
وتبطل شحنات كثيره جدا ونحن بنعتمد في هذا
الموضوع على تحديد مسارات امنه
وكل ما يطول المده بتاعه الهدنه المصحوبه
يعني بنيه قويه من طرفي النزاع دي
حتساعدني جدا في نحاول نعالج او المفاهيم
في علاج هذه الازمه الموجوده هذه الهدنه
ربما تساهم في تسهيل الوصول هذه المساعدات
لكم لكن كيف تنعكس على جهودكم على الارض
الى اي مدى لمستم قدره اكبر على التحرك
خلال الايام الماضيه مع استمرار تمديد هذه
الهدن
يتم
بالمناسبه رغم المحدوديته
الانتشار الافقي وغير الدعم المستشفيات
بالكوادر المتخصصه في الاسعافات الاوليه
والرعايه الصحيه دعم المستشفيات ساعدتنا
في لحاد كبير سهوله الحركه في محاوله جمع
ما تيسر من الجسامين الموجوده لان دلوقتي
الخطر الداهم والكبير هو
الجسامين المتوفين المنتشرين في مختلف
انحاء العاصمه الخرطوم فضلا عن الولايات
الثانيه اللي هي تشهد نزاع مسلحه ولايات
حاليا اشتد فيها النزاع بين الطرفين ايضا
وبحكمه علاقتنا نحن برضو على مستوى
الولايات وفروعنا في الهلال الاحمر عندنا
اتصالات مع طرفي النزاع وبنقوم بادوار
كبيره جدا لانه الهلال الاحمر على
المساعدات الطبيه
ومتعدد جوانب كثيره جدا
فهي لمساله كويسه جدا ونحن بنحاول ندعم في
استمرار هذه الهدنه وتجديد
وصولا الى هدنه دائما ان شاء الله عشان
نقدر نحن نعمل اشياء كثيره طبعا واحده من
المخاطر الكبيره جدا اللي هي الجثث
الملقاه لانه دلوقتي
ممكن تدي امطار لو جاءت امطار حتكون كارثه
كبيره جدا لانه
مياه الامطار حتمشي في
المصارف الناس حتشرب منها
الحيوانات هتشرب منها وحتكون
لاعداد الجثث المنتشره في الخرطوم وباقي
الولايات التي شهدت اشتباكات
والله لا ما عندنا احصائيات ثابته نحن
عاده ما بنعتمد على احصائيات اي جهه
تعملها رغم انه في احصائيتين
وليس احصائيات تقديرات
والله هي التقديرات حنقول بالمئات في
الجثث الموجوده ضحايا وبالالاف طبعا
المصابين والمجروحين لكن نحن محدد
لاستحاله رقم محدد يعني اليوم منظمه الصحه
العالميه عندها قدرات هائله جدا وعندها
خبرات قديمه جدا وكبيره في تحديد الوفيات
الصحه العالميه قالت انه
الجثه حتى الان على مستوى الخرطوم طبعا
وفي اكثر من
1300 مصاب ووزاره الصحه اعلنت هذه الارقام
ونقابات
والاتحادات بتاعه الاطباء قالوا كده
معناها شو معناها هي
الجثث ما اقل من القنصليه الجثه لكن نحن
كهلال احمد سوداني ما عندنا احصائيه دقيقه
فهي
التحديات التي تواجهونها هل لديكم مشكله
في الامن هل تتعرض فرقكم خصوصا من
المتطوعين الى اي تهديدات خلال عملهم
لا ما في تحديات مباشره للمطورين لانه
الطرفيه النزاع سواء كان القوات المسلحه
والدعم السريع يعلمون الدول الهلال الاحمر
وحياده وانه لا ينتمي لاي جهه معينه
وبالتالي ما في بالنسبه لهم ما في فائده
من عمل الهلال الاحمر السوداني لكن هذا لا
يعني انه بعض المنتسبين الى اي من هذه
القوات قد ما يكونوا عارفين الدور بتاعه
هلال الاحمر وفي خضم الاشتباكات الميدانيه
ممكن يحصل ارتداء علينا لكن ما اعتداء
مقصود طبعا
موجوده
بتحصل في مجموعات بتكون شاي للسلاح وبتكون
منتشره
بتنهب وتفرق ونحن في في خرطوم تم
اول او الامس تم سلب الاعتداء على سيارتين
من سيارات الجمعيه من الفرع بتاعنا في
الخرطوم وتم نحب هذه السيارات لكن الغريب
ان الناس النهبوا السيارات هذه الماره
شالوا ازالوا كل العلامات تحت الهلال
الاحمر
واخذوا السيارات اثنين سيارات لاند
من الاشياء
فيما يتعلق بجهودكم لمساعده المصابين هل
هناك اعداد اسره كافيه في المستشفيات
لاستقبالهم
من خلال دعمنا للمستشفيات من خلال الكوادر
الرعايه الصحيه الاوليه في ناس بيحصل لهم
علاج وقتي واصاباته ما بتكون خطرها
عشان نفضي خانات زياده لكن المستشفيات ما
بتقدر تستوعب العدد الكبير جدا من
المصابين فضلا للمناسبه فضلا عن الناس
اللي بتردد المستويات في الظروف العاديه
يعني في ناس عيانين العياء عادي ما مصابين
يعني وفي ناس بيمشي المستشفيات بيعملوا
غسيناهم غسيل الدولي للكلى مثلا في ناس
بيتبدوا على المستشفيات لامراض عاديه في
المستشفيات ديت صعب جدا انها تستوعب العدد
الكبير من المرضى العاديين اضافه للمصابين
يعني هناك تحاول يعني
شكرا جزيلا على وجودك معنا اسامه ابو بكر
المسؤول الاعلامي للعلال الاحمر السوداني
كنت معنا من الخرطوم عبر الهاتف
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات